[Музика]
Привіт усім і ласкаво просимо на
сьогоднішній урок англійської мови, ми відкриємо
два дивовижні місця на земній кулі та
досліджуємо форму інфінітиву дієслова,
але перш ніж поглянути на цю фразу,
нам нічого втрачати і  світ, щоб
побачити, як ви розумієте це нічого не
втрачати, що це означає, що ми не можемо зробити
речі гіршими, але у нас є світ, щоб побачити,
що весь світ чекає, коли нас
відкриють, тому давайте розпочнемо нашу подорож,
подивіться на картинку  що ви можете
сказати про це місто, яке воно, чи б
ви хотіли його відвідати, що б ви
там робили, це найкраще місто лазні на
річці, навіть що ви знаєте про це
місто, тому подивіться на ці фотографії,
прочитайте текст і  знайдіть рядки про
ці малюнки
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож, що ви дізналися про математику та
що означають ці картинки, давайте
перевіримо перше зображення, це римські лазні,
безумовно, наступне воно смачне так
традиційна страва смачна і третє
насправді це вулиця
як це називається, це Royal Crescent
Crescent, дайте мені сісти, а тепер подумайте про
три речі, які ви хотіли б побачити або зробити
в цьому місті, то що це може бути, щоб
відвідати автобуси з цілющою водою або
прогулятися цією знаменитою вулицею, кажуть,
що це  є пам'ятками Англії або
скуштувати цю страву, паштет, що б
ти ще хотів зробити, дитино, давайте прочитаємо цей
текст ще раз і цього разу зосередимося на
підкреслених словах, давайте читаємо разом,
але коштовність зла. У мене багато приємних
спогадів про моє  час навчався в лазні, і
я намагався читати
якомога частіше. Це прекрасне місто
на південному заході Англії на річці
Ейвон з інтригуючою історією
, елегантна архітектура Римської Берти
та галасливі вулиці роблять його ідеальним
місцем для відвідувачів, якими були римляни.
перший, хто скористався єдиними гарячими
джерелами у Великій Британії, які
витікають з глибини
землі,
люди приїжджали звідусіль, щоб скупатися
в цілющій воді, я люблю ходити
навколо стародавніх автобусів і відвідувати
архітектура
прогулятися містом і, безсумнівно, відкриє
деякі коштовності, включаючи Королівський Півмісяць,
вулицю виняткової грузинської
архітектури та одну з визначних пам'яток
Англії після довгої прогулянки, єдине, що
можна зробити, це просто зупинитися випити чашку чаю та
пасти.  Традиційно пиріжки - це тістечка з
начинкою з м'яса або сиру, але сьогодні
ви можете знайти різноманітні начинки
курка тікка - мій улюблений
Бет, безумовно, захоплююче місто
від стародавнього до Мортона, завжди є
що відкрити, я б тільки
хотів б відвідувати частіше
тому підкресліть слова, якою частиною мови
є вони, їх інфінітиви безумовно
і настав час бабусі сказати, що ми
говоримо про інфінітивну форму
мережі, подивіться на речення
з тексту знайди інфінітив Thea я
намагаюся повернути добре були першими  to make
use nice something to discover and find
after can давайте розглянемо, що є
інфінітивом
це основна форма дієслова, воно зазвичай
починається з b  irth - і за
ним слідує основна форма дієслова.
У словнику можна знайти дієслова в формі інфінітиву,
тому інфінітиви вони можуть бути через
інфінітив with to chew play work gole
infinitive without to just play get
when use full infinitive and after  які
дієслова ми маємо використовувати голий інфінітив, тож
давайте пограємо та перевіримо, що ваше завдання полягатиме в
тому, щоб вибрати після дієслів, які ви можете побачити
на цьому екрані, з якою нескінченністю слід
використовувати повний інфінітив, щоб дозволити собі
грати, чи голий інфінітив дозволити грати, і
натисніть відповідну кнопку  добре, давайте пограємо
, давайте почнемо погоджуюсь я погоджуюся грати
або я згоден грати я згоден грати повний
інфінітив право наступне слово дозволяти або
давайте грати обов'язково давайте грати
прямо наступний знімок ви повинні грати, щоб грати
ви повинні грати голий інфінітив добре
наступного  F word робить залп, щоб бути ми можемо
дозволити собі грати в ігри ми можемо дозволити собі це
емоційний cespedes volatile
nice наступний хочу я хочу грати однозначно
я хочу грати переконатися, що
співведучі choi  ce Robert a, хто може змусити
вас грати в цю гру, хто може змусити вас грати в
неї. Наступна була б краще, я краще
грай, а потім навчайся правильно, але тобі
краще вчитися, ніж грати добре, виріши, що
вирішив, що ти вирішив грати правильно, ти
вирішив грати в KITT  Я б хотів пограти
Я б хотів пограти в цю гру гарно Я
сподіваюся грати в неї годину і я можу
грати протягом довгого часу Я можу грати в наступну
Мені вдалося зіграти Мені вдалося
зіграти в гру ось список  зі
слів, які ми використовували під час гри, швидко
подумайте та виберіть, за якими з них
йде повний інфінітив із до, а
після якого – голий інфінітив,
не витрачаючи жодної хвилини, і розділіть
ці слова на дві колонки,
давайте перевіримо, що ви маєте
право  сказати погоджуюсь зробити щось вдалося,
але можна без - можу грати цей
у значенні взаємність співрозмовника
реєстр з моїми батьками змушувала мене робити
миття посуду в дитинстві звертати увагу
тільки на активний після make these
gole infinitive в пасивному ми використовуємо full
in  Наприклад, у дитинстві
мене змусили мити посуд, тому мої
батьки змусили мене мити посуд, але я
був змушений мити посуд правильно,
говорив про інфінітиви, вони можуть
бути до інфінітиву або через інфінітив,
і це використовується  після таких дієслів або голого
інфінітиву без вас, і ми використовуємо його
після таких моделей, як can shoot after let
make does дійсний загальний вибір щодо
mucho body або після таких фраз, як
краще б краще я краще залишився
вдома я б скоріше пішов з тобою
правильно
тепер давайте зосередимося на карті розуму та
визначимо цілі використання
інфінітивів foo спочатку ми використовуємо повні
інфінітиви, щоб виразити мету або
прихильність наміру, наприклад я
хочу бачити світ, це мій намір я
хочу робити те, що бачити, де я  дзвоню,
щоб запитати вас про це.
Я дзвоню вам, для чого запитати.
Подивіться на
це завдання: зіставити частини
речень, а потім перефразувати їх,
використовуючи інфінітиви,
наприклад, вона відкрила  вікно,
яка мета, для чого вибрати
правильний кінець, можливо, вона хотіла провітрити
свою спальню правильно, тож давайте перефразуємо це,
вона відкрила вікно, щоб провітрити свою спальню,
або вона відкрила вікно, щоб провітрити
свою спальню, щоб дозволити господарю
погойдати вас  повернути зараз,
блін, давайте перевіримо, щоб вона пішла з дому о
5:00 не пропустити свій потяг не
пропустити свій поїзд Latasha chop Netezza від Nestle
не пропустити отримати наступний вона
забронювала рейс заздалегідь, щоб не
мати проблем з її відправленням скажімо  вона
забронювала авіарейс заздалегідь, щоб не
мати проблем або уникнути проблем,
і останній з них їй довелося змінити свій
маршрут, щоб дістатися до парку відпочинку
раніше, усе це цілі, які ми використовуємо
повний інфінітив для вираження мети вона
зробила щось для того, щоб  робити щось
інше правильно добре давайте перейдемо до іншої
функції ми використовуємо повний інфінітив після
деяких дієслів ми вже грали в гру
та визначили ці дієслова right get ми
можемо рухатися далі ми використовуємо інфінітив після
прикметника  з перших уроків
у школі ми пам'ятаємо фразу доброго
ранку доброго ранку я радий тебе бачити
я радий тебе бачити я радий
тебе бачити або мені шкода чути, що
після прикметників ми вживаємо  до нескінченності
давайте спочатку виконаємо деякі дії. Знайдіть
прикметники в цих питаннях у
першому прикметнику
зручніше,
у другому краще отримати відповідь на
ці запитання про себе
, чи зручніше подорожувати
поїздом чи літаком,
чому добре та  по-друге, краще
провести активний або розслабляючий відпочинок, який
тип відпочинку ви віддаєте перевагу, чому ще
одна ідея ми використовуємо повний інфінітив після
прикметників з двома і досить, але спочатку
давайте згадаємо місце слова, щоб
закінчити слово досить прикметником, і ми
використовуйте перед прикметником it's too good
to be true right it's too good
the not the dobra it's ticket right
і слово досить, яке ми використовуємо після
прикметника,
і ми можемо сказати, що ви достатньо вмієте
робити це досить добре, але де
інфінітиви давайте спочатку виконаємо кілька
завдань давайте перефразуємо найкращі речення,
використовуючи нескінченність перше речення
валіза важка, ви не можете нести її
самостійно, давайте трохи змінимо це
валіза занадто важка, щоб носити її, тому
ще раз валіза занадто важка
нести дитину і друге речення
кімната вже хроба, тому кімната
досить хробачна, ви не можете вимкнути опалення,
зараз кімната достатньо тепла, щоб її нагріти,
подумайте про свої власні закінчення цих
речень погода надто погана, щоб
робити все добре, і наша машина досить швидка, щоб
завершити речення правильно, скажи Т плюс
прикметники, а потім обдурити інфінітив або
прикметники плюс досить, а потім до
нескінченності отримати це один, який ми використовуємо повний
інфінітив у цих фразах
перший останній найгірший найкращий наприклад
він остання людина, яка найняла
ми, Остін Нікотра Бхануматі, він
остання людина, яка найняла дитину, де
найкращий час для подорожі найкращий час для
подорожі комплект
давайте більше практикуємо, зверніть увагу на
цю таблицю  першим щось зробити
наприклад першим прийти
я завжди перший приходить в
офіс у нього є bleep дирижабль Ріжо загнав
офіс перший прийшов отримати давайте подумаємо
про українські відповідники до цих
фраз скажи, що він не той чоловік
передумати як сказати по-українськи
він не той чоловік передумати
метал ти сильна Венера для
євразійця все ж наступного вона
перша увійшла до кімнати вана пара шрі раві
зарізати його неслухняна англійською вона була
там спочатку ввести це наступний у мене
немає часу сперечатися з вами далі
зараз час сперечатися з вами знаю, що я
вирішив кип'ятити духовність, сер немає часу
сперечатися,
повторюйте цю фразу я не маю часу
сперечатися з вами далі отримати і
нарешті, у такій ситуації можна зробити лише одну
річ, приховані емоції, яких ніхто не
побачить, супутник бачить англійською, є
лише одна річ, яку можна зробити добре,
тепер давайте перефразуємо подивимося на
приклад,
він єдиний  той, хто може нам допомогти,
він єдиний, хто нам допомагає, але давайте сформулюємо
другу фразу, це найкраще місце,
яке я міг відвідати, це найкраще місце
для відвідування комплект і останнє вона була
останньою людиною, яка покинула літак, якою вона була
останній залишив літак безперечно,
щоб залишити комплект, це більше, що
запитальні слова говорять після запитальних слів, які
ми використовуємо до інфінітиву, за одним винятком,
давайте прочитаємо приклади, тому перший
каже мені, коли натискати кнопку, підкаже мені,
коли натискати Колі
ні  сніжний день, коли натиснути добре
другий ти розумієш, що робити
розумієш, що робити повний інфінітив
good але зверни увагу на останнє
питання чому б не запитати його зараз
чому б не запитати голий інфінітив без
давайте муштрувати такі фрази то чому б не запитати
Шон Мун - це патотті, твоя черга, чому б
не запитати, куди, чому б не спробувати переміститися.
Прабхаваті, чому б не спробувати ще раз, чому б
не спробувати встановити інфінітив, ми використовуємо інфінітив
після запитальних слів хто коли де як
але після чому голий інфінітив без
ви чому б не спробували давайте попрактикуємося,
щоб правило було в таблиці що робити,
коли робити, де робити і як робити, але
чому б не робити це використовувати дієслово в
правильній формі перша фраза скажіть мені,
як заповнити цю форму  правильно, як
до другого, чому б не спробувати голий
інфінітив, правий, а останнє, куди
покласти свої сумки, куди покласти супер, отримати
інфінітив зазвичай плутають з
герундієм інфінітив через інфінітив і
герундій web plus Inc грають чому вони
плутаються, оскільки вони вживаються після
різні слова або іноді навіть після
тих самих дієслів, давайте перевіримо, наскільки добре ви
це пам'ятаєте, і ми знову гратимемо в
гру в цій грі, вашим завданням
буде вирішити, куди поставити ці дієслова
після деяких з них, ми використовуємо інфінітив,
як я погодився допомогти  you infinity в
той час як після інших ми використовуємо герундій, як
я люблю грати правильно процес скажімо
давайте грати разом
готові стабільно давайте грати get set і
перше дієслово goes
спробуйте щось складне спробуйте зробити, щоб зробити
нескінченність правильно supe  r інший
продовжуй продовжувати робити герундій гарно наступний
Я хотів би
грати в цю гру супер наступну зупинку
Джеральд перестати говорити
гарно Я не можу не закохатися на ім'я
Міна Сако Хадасса спробуйте зробити щось
інше, якщо це так  новий досвід Я не
можу допомогти вам назвати мене, кого
я обожнюю робити цю дитину. Обіцяю допомогти
вам, щоб допомогти вам це зробити, просто змішайте
цей чай Ruby Мені подобається подорожувати,
так добре, якщо вам потрібно
більше практики у виборі  після яких
дієслова ми використовуємо до нескінченності або герундій, ви
можете грати в цю гру самостійно, використовуйте
QR-код і продовжуйте, і настав
час, щоб отримати домашнє завдання, спершу
заповніть карту розуму своїми власними
реченнями, кожна група має принаймні два
речення  праворуч і друга частина
вашого домашнього завдання встановіть рекорд у
грі, як вам це подобається отримати лук
виграє і урок закінчено, слідкуйте за
оновленнями і до скорого побачення, до побачення
[Музика]
ви